[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
[Music]
it's Tuesday you know what that means
you don't even cheers have never happens
on the Tuesday job has it already begun
it's the Friendship added hello Tom hi
I'm just reluctant to put on my cans
because I think I have slightly Debonair
hair today you have lovely hair today if
you don't make me sick
in it maybe I can put it on one it's
like a porcupine yeah how's it going
what's the difference between uh
porcupine and a hedgehog well the
different animals that's the same what's
the difference between a cow and a horse
they're different what's the difference
well they're different right different
animals uh poor Cooper Hedgehog uh
traditionally more associated with I
would say the European continents thank
you porcupine South America and of
course Africa porcupine bigger Longer
quills they can't shoot the quills who
can shoot their clothes none of them can
shoot the quotes
well don't say it again well it's just a
lot something good A lot of people make
out that you know if you see a porcupine
it'll turn around and fire quills it
won't it'll back up to you you know at
speed but it can't fire its course but
the interesting thing about a porcupine
quill is at the end when it goes into
the animal when it when the end of the
quill gets exposed to moisture blood the
quill then splits it splinters right so
a kind of a needle goes in but then the
needle fractures in the animal's body
awful oh have you seen those images of
dogs when they've had a porcupine and
they've got it all over yeah and the
dog's like that sorry man it's enough
where are we going vets are we
that's I feel as if the end of this is
fractured inside me I mean I'm having a
rough day already and now we're off to
the vets who's gonna pull all these out
okay will you do it again yeah I'll
probably do it now yeah I'll do it again
um we're both wearing quite lovely uh
Adidas uh tops brilliantly I love Adidas
I like Adidas too did you ever have a
little Palmer internet skill to remember
Adidas oh go on we used to say uh dog it
did ah [ __ ] and did it down uh stank
what's the stank a step it's not gonna
stank is like um you know where the rain
water goes in the road right what do you
what do you call that a drain yeah a
drain yeah it's called the stank great
Scottish word isn't it
um a dog get dead that [ __ ] and did it
don't understand and supposedly the name
of uh Adidas comes from the uh guy who
created whose name is Adolf dassler so
he dropped a little bit of his first
name and a little bit of his last name
because he thought probably won't be
able to sell shoes as easily if I call
them adolfs so I'll call him Adidas and
his brother
created the uh clothing line and shoe
line Puma or does it say in the United
States Puma yeah isn't that crazy two
warring brothers one's Adidas one's Puma
was it the sister that did Nike
that'd be a great story uh dude the Nike
thing was uh it was a guy just making
running shoes wasn't he and then it just
exploded what these shoes exploding yeah
terrible shoes yeah he was making a very
just simple running shoe for an athlete
it did well and from there he's created
arguably the most famous
shoe now right
I'm not these are Adidas too these are
Manchester United's user and wear my
England shirt hey I heard of do you have
that thing where you're doing
um you don't mix like you don't wear
Nike shoes and Adidas top
now I think I'd be more inclined to mix
I don't like it when I'm all matchy but
today it's just I'm doing a bit of an
Adidas thing I I knew a guy at the gym
and if he had an Adidas top and naked
shots he wouldn't go into the gym oh
that's weird to go home that's strange I
would never do double denim though would
you never never I would never do denim
jeans in a denim shirt or even denim
jeans and a denim jacket would you
uh I've played in a band once when I was
a lot younger and that was our thing
that was double denim all of us what was
the band called
uh
I think we were called foreign country
at that time not bad foreign country
like that but it was double denim with
like patches sound uh stitched on and
that um I'm always nervous when a band
when a band's first single is the name
of the band I feel like that's death for
the band you know what I mean Big
Country ah big kids
living in a box living in a box right
let's get one more because there should
be three gosh Men at Work no no I think
they there's a little land from out down
under right yeah first time I ever heard
Vegemite the word Vegemite she just
smiled and gave me a Vegemite Sandwich
ah what happened I slashed myself with
the sauce yeah these swords they're
actually dead now they've I think these
swords have actually been sharp and I
feel them yeah somebody's got it against
us I think anyway Dom sorry Carrie I'm
sword against me I'll ask you a question
here it's a tough question
well it's a two-part question you should
hope you get the first one what was the
name of the dog who found the stolen
Jewels remain World Cup trophy remember
very famous Doug go again go again what
was the name of the dog right who found
the stolen World Cup trophy the Jews
remained trophy
ever get stolen that's still on the
original trophy it was found by a by a
dock worker I think I could give it
three guesses if you want go on it's a
classic dog name
now I wouldn't say it's a classic dog
name I'll give you a clue purchase close
two syllables
yep it's a type of food that's your
second clue
um
no it's a vegetable that's your last
clue
uh carrot
for a dog why not I might have had red
here pickles no okay you've never heard
that name he actually featured in his
own film he was at the because this is
the year that England won the World Cup
he was at the party that the World Cup
team were at he was like an honored
guest the dog
was he a plus one I think he probably
did have a plus one yeah Catherine but
the real question I was going to ask if
you don't know the name of the dog
you're never going to get this question
well Alaska anyway because we've already
gone down this road how did pickles die
wow that's an unusual yeah
but let's let's make this as uh we'll
call it six questions I'm allowed to ask
you six questions
is it did he die in any sort of
transport
no right
did he die
was anyone involved in his death
just the dog himself just a dog
was any mechanical or or something
electric involved nothing electric is it
almost you could almost describe it as a
natural phenomenon a natural Mouse
was a wet type of weather
you can't call it weather but was it a
natural so I don't think an
environmental issue had anything to do
with it not an environmental bar yeah
but like I sort of let me narrow it here
would you put it in a group of
say uh like quicksand drowning
of a heavy a heavy wind it's a naturally
occurring thing on our planet that was
in some way responsible for Pickle's
death was it lightning no
you must be all right
so it's not it was a naturally occurring
thing something that occurs on our
planet that we see all the time that had
that in some way had something to do
with Pickle's death does it in any way
involve trees it does involve trees did
he get hit by a coconut in England or
was it England
then add a phone uh Branch when you
close weather yeah you're close because
it's to do with the tree you are close
how else may a dog potentially hurt
himself or tragically kill himself with
a tree something falling from the tree
it's not something for them we've
established that oh but I thought just
the cooking up so could he have been
trapped in the tree
in a way yeah because of the um the root
the root system no it's not the roots
and he wasn't trapped and it gets stuck
on it
how did he get stuck on a tree and die
what kind of trees get stuck on tell me
it's actually really sad
it's tragic comedy he hung himself
by a tree he was he got he escaped from
his owner and he was attached to a lead
or a leash in the United States and he
jumped and the lead got trapped around a
branch and he hung himself that dumb
that is why I don't like to see dogs
running with Alicia if you get trapped
on anything yeah for one thing I never
hooked on the caller
on his neck anyway I always go for the
bloody one Bobby Bobby Johnson any dog
but never I've seen people who do that
they let their dog run off why don't you
hook a lead directly to a neck collar do
you think it's too cruel to the dog well
I don't know I don't know if it's cruel
but you're just like a neck is a very
I mean you catch is on I mean you don't
want something on your neck do you no
you don't
very sad I came down to your house on
Saturday I've not seen your dog for a
couple of weeks and he did that lovely
thing that he does when I've not seen
him for a little bit but he's very
excited and then he was Keen for me to
sit down and once I sat down he
physically dominated me for a good five
minutes to me crawled up on me and he
sat right here he just was like my human
for a sec and once he kind of figured
that out he then went and sat next to
your wife that's his favorite position
in it and what did I do that was for you
though
uh you allowed me to eat Thai food in
your house no there's got to do with
Bobby
Bobby
you won't know so I'll just tell you
bought me a lovely bottle of wine
specifically for me I saw Sarah he loves
that he loves something oh I know yeah
dear dogs teeth cleaned because he can
sometimes be a little bit wiffy because
the last time you were down you said his
breath was absolutely honking well even
you and your wife are like oh Bob what's
going on there so I got I got his teeth
cleaned is it back to normal now
stinking again well they'll eat crazy
stuff
Reserve Bar is your online source for
premium and luxury Spirits wine and
champagne and now Reserve Bar offers
same day delivery Reserve Bar has a vast
lineup of rare and hard to find bottles
premium Brands celebrities spirits and
limited releases that you just won't
find in your local store I know no one
does Spirit gifting better than Reserve
Bar you're looking for an elevated gift
reservebar.com has you covered and you
can have that gift delivered right to
their door even better turn that
spirit's gift into a cherished Memento
with custom engraving perfect for
birthdays weddings anniversaries
Father's Day you name it yeah getting
into home bartending Reserve Bar has
everything you need Spirits for the
shells sure but they also have every
barware tool and glass you need Reserve
bars a great feature called cocktail
lounge this is a treasure Trove of
cocktail rest bartending tips interviews
with Master distillers celebrities and
more and the hot trending Spirits Billy
is ready to drink cocktails have you
tried them yes they're delicious you're
drinking one right now they taste better
than ever and Reserve Bar has a huge
collection of them these canned
cocktails are great for parties when you
don't have time to tend the bar or for
tailgating season which supposedly is uh
fully in swing right now Reserve Bar
also has barware glassware cocktail
recipes and more need something for a
party tonight Reserve Bar now offers
same day delivery straight to your door
did you forget that special birthday
gift Reserve Bar to the rescue with
same-day delivery visit reservebar.com
today and use promo code onion to save
ten dollars off your purchase of 75 or
more on Spirits wine or pre-made
cocktails but only when you use our
special offer at reservebar.com with the
code onion that's reservebar.com and
code onion this offer expires December
31st 2022 hey
hey we should try and get through as
much stuff as possible come on it's just
me and you this week Dom
sometimes my favorite I like other
people but you know what Dante said well
hell is other people hey Billy should we
peel the onion yes let's peel the onion
as it Well Done
peeling The Onion
you got any questions from anyone shall
I start doing my glasses yeah while you
look at the glasses this is from Dan de
shelter that's a cool name is that a
Scottish name sounds a nice ghost it's a
shelter I don't think so there makes it
sound like it's French or something yeah
you might be right anyway he says hello
uh Billy and dumb love you both thank
you very much but my question is for
Billy oh my family's been researching
our family tree in the last few years
and it turns out Billy and I are both
part of the clan Boyd my grandmother's
maiden name was Boyd and her dad came
from Scotland I was wondering if you've
ever gone to the clan castle in
Kilmarnock thanks lots of love to you
both for providing uh tons of anything
over the years well how sweet you found
a family member family member a clan
member so there was a clan you see Dom
it's basically a big gang gang yeah just
had a bit of an area and that's how
Clans worked you know so different Clans
went with other different Clans if there
was a war or whatever and apparently the
boys were the layers of kilmanok Lords
is that and is that okay yeah right and
uh yeah I've never been to the castle
actually Dan I don't know if you have
but uh maybe we could go together
I've been a commander but I'm not even
sure if there's a castle to be honest
but the thing was when England took over
Scotland they made it illegal they have
cleanse
they didn't want the clients because
then they could you could get together
so they made it um they made it illegal
to wear your tongue that's how you could
tell who was in your clan you know you
had a kill with the right Tartan you go
oh he's wearing boy Tartan he's with the
boys
so we made it illegal it were turned and
he made it illegal he speak Gaelic
most people could only speak Gaelic so
that made it difficult didn't it well
they try to force him to speak English
oh these English people sound like girl
right one of the worst things he did
if you get married
the English Lord who was looking over
you he had to have a night with your
wife before you well just uh
watching the Telly maybe no strictly
Ballroom or something making love done
to try and get rid of this Scottish
lines what do you think of that well I
wouldn't be happy well you wouldn't be
happy would you supposed to be a
romantic evening for you and your wife
and you say see you the day after
tomorrow yeah they had that in
Braveheart then yeah what if she came
back and she did all right great time
how was your night brilliant I've
reconsidered the marriage actually
but there you go no I've never seen the
castle but uh good good good to look
back at the history isn't it
Scotland has a wonderful history full of
if you don't mind me saying wonderful
people
hey Tom Josh Singleton hey Josh
hi guys Your Love of food always makes
me happy
I eat three times a day makes me happy
you know me and my girlfriend take the
Mickey out of each other because we
don't like certain foods that are you
know Common I don't like pizza for
instance and she doesn't like cooked
onion
what is the most common food that you
don't actually like P.S I love your show
well he doesn't like pizza that's that's
a slightly strange one not liking cooked
onion I don't think he's as weird as not
liking Pizza you know
but do you want a a secret about cooked
onions on
yeah is this a secret that a cooked
onion told you one time no so you cook
an onion yeah do you like getting like a
curry from a Chinese restaurant
oh I only add the Chinese Curry go on
right do you know the thing I'm talking
about I think you know you see I'll have
a chicken curry for instance yes yeah
Chinese with a race and the onions
always nice it's kind of
crispy it's got a it's got a bait to it
yeah what have they done
and whenever I cooked it the onion
always get too too cooked a bit sloppy
yeah right and I was I went to my local
Chinese restaurant and I said how do you
do that yeah I can get everything else
working got the sauce got the check I
got it all good yeah kangaroo they told
me what you do right do you want me to
tell you deep fry it no you're doing
deep fry it
oh you don't cook it in the sauce and
everything done
he cut it up to the size that you want
but just sprinkle of water
sprinkle water a little bit of water on
it
stick it in the microwave two minutes oh
wait until everything else is ready put
it in right at the end so the microwave
has cooked it slightly
and then it's another song right and the
cook they're so slightly continues to
cook it a little bit but not much not a
lot keeps it crunchy because you're
serving it right then so you've got the
chickens delicious the sauce is perfect
and the onion gives you that little bit
lovely well one of the things that my my
mum and dad do make a great Curry one of
the things that they have is a little
side thing if you want it is some finely
chopped up Red Onion so you get your
Curry and you sprinkle on top that's raw
raw indeed red though it's red onion
though you know it's easy to eat bro
it's lovely it's lovely what's the one
thing local
um doesn't have to be local
common is the word
Josh said it is common most people like
let's say above 80 but you think to
yourself I don't like that
all right well this is a big food I am
which is why I'm choosing it I'm not
saying that I don't like it right but
it's not it's not my thing if someone
said you could never eat it again it
wouldn't bother me chocolate
I just it's fine
but I'm not the guy reaching for the the
chocolates in a box when they show up if
someone gives me a bit of chocolate I'll
have a square or two I'll be like yeah
it's fine it just doesn't I have to
agree with you though it doesn't
and I find it kind of clags in my mouth
a little bit I mean if it's dark dark
chocolate I'll take it you know I'll
take it Vigo is a big fan of chocolate
wasn't he when we were doing Rings yeah
most of the time you could say it's a
Vigo do you got a bit of chocolate and
you'd be like if you didn't have it on
him he'd be like give me a couple
minutes I'll get it for you you knew
where it was yeah he knew where it was
and also our friend Carrie our friend
Nigel's wife she has to have a piece of
chocolate a day every day every day in
the evening before she goes to bed
she'll have a piece of chocolate before
bed yeah like if we're all hanging out
watching a movie she'll usually pull out
some element of chocolate round about
you know nine o'clock ten o'clock and
she'll have a couple of little bits and
then send her off to bed ladies love
chocolate it's weird there yeah um yeah
I'll give you that one chocolate well
we're both saying chocolate oh no oh
chocolate was my answer don't steal it
as you know I don't like cinnamon but
that's not that's a flavor isn't it done
but if it was common either food that I
don't really eat the other people lately
I like it I love eating everything do
you like a hot dog I've never seen you
eat a hot dog I've enjoyed the hot dog
in my life yeah all right well we'll
move on this from Jason Arthur in
Delaware United States what did Delaware
boys what did Delaware
there is a song Tom that does every one
of the 50 states
so you can learn it so you get well you
isn't that amazing though somebody sat a
songwriter Sat one day and he says I'm
going to write a song
that's got all the states in it but used
in a wheel at that Delaware what did
Della wear
and a x through all 50 states is what
what uh what an achievement what an
incredible achievement um
the remember the TV show Roseanne which
I think is now called the Connors right
because uh
the Roseanne character in it uh I think
like falls down dead in one of the
latest Seasons they lived on Delaware
Street and I think they lived in
Delaware as a state but that might not
be right Eddie could we find that out
but they definitely lived on Delaware
Street yeah I love that show oh thank
you Eddie oh here's a question from
Jason Arthur in Delaware he says good
day gentlemen what a lovely start so
great to listen to you both each week
keep up the good work I will be flying
to Auckland in mid-november and be there
for only one day I plan to rent a car
and would love to get a glimpse of the
hobbiton set at the very least my
question is what would you guys
recommend to a Lord of the Rings fan to
do in just one day and even if it's not
specifically Lord the Rings Focus
whereas a cool close-ish place to
Auckland
that you remember fondly lovely little
belts there one day one day in Auckland
one day
that's right I think I think it's lame
is that lovely that wouldn't it yeah she
had a dream that um
a life would be a lot better than having
to donate her teeth and her hair just to
stay alive of course you had that dream
I had a dream that my life would be so
much better than what is going on right
now yeah no one dreams that they're
gonna have to donate all of their teeth
and hair just to live yeah babe my God
Danny Hathaway what time I went to see
her the other day Tom what'd you say uh
a new play but I'd enjoyed the new play
but even more than the play I listened
to Hamilton on the way rent in the way
back oh bro yeah that's great me and my
wife was saying that it taught me our
voices love them actually I'm not very
well versed on the rent songs apart from
1 200 000 3 000 minutes but Hamilton one
achievement
right stuff to do in one day well you
and I climbed was it the was it the sky
tower in Auckland yeah you me and uh
Elijah Wood we climbed the uh Sky Tower
that's right that was really Sushi can't
remember the name of the sushi
restaurant
um because if you go to Auckland we if
you're wanting to do locations a lot of
rings kind of things we didn't really go
up that far not really we stopped about
air hobbiting which was neon Nelson yeah
he's hoping to rent a car and get to the
hobbiton set in a day could he get there
you could you could actually get that I
would say do that if you want to do a
lot of rings thing yeah get yourself to
the green dragon quick beer back up
again and there you'll be on your next
flight otherwise I would do what Dom
says I would go up the tower and then
maybe go to the harbor remember we went
out in the boats um so that's really fun
uh auckland's a lovely place was it did
we go to Auckland for the Americas cup
that we're dead was that Auckland yeah
yeah so the harbor is beautiful it's
really beautiful and you know what I
love when you arrive in New Zealand done
if you remember you arrive
internationally and then you have to go
to another terminal
to do the little flight domestic from
Auckland to uh Wellington and you follow
a line that's rented on the ground to
get to the I used to love that I like
that too don't know it was like it was
like
it was like getting home wasn't it yeah
before when that little lane that took
you to the domestic terminal and also
after being slightly cooped up on planes
and in buildings it's nice
just a little walks Lovely isn't it 10
15 minute walk just oh he's gonna sneeze
he's gonna sneeze multiple times he's
thinking about it it's gone yeah oh it's
gone it's gone but it could save your
life that walk as well
because of that deep vein thrombosis
yeah I know a guy that got that really
yeah still alive yeah he said but his
doctor said if he hadn't came
to see him
he could have been the end no I'm not a
doctor I don't think you are yet is that
a
it's like a swelling in the veins a
trapped vein I would say like a blood
clot which is bad in your leg
terrible in your groin
and a killer in your lung you don't in
your brain either you don't want to get
up in your brain and the way that you
get rid of it is to be active on the
plane is it do a little bit of this
always yeah because it will start oh
starting your calf wouldn't it so you
want to be moving your calf yeah
we've got another question shall I do
this and then you do the last one right
gone this from C Fisher didn't give
their first name Carol could be could be
Carol fishing Kathy yeah said hi my name
is oh they're actually called Fisher but
why is the C in front anyway hi my
name's fish I'm from Pennsylvania in the
United States kind of the middle knuckle
of the pointer finger if you hold your
thumb up you know done the middle
knuckle of the first finger pointer
about there there you go okay thank you
and she spoke German here hello
the gate it's good I hope that you are
good
you speak a little bit of German as well
yeah one of your favorite countries
she says just wanted to tell you both
that your podcast is fantastic well
actually she says absolutely amazing but
I didn't want to flex that hard uh it
truly gets me through the day if I could
ask a question it would be did you ever
Envy a line or a stunt or something that
the other had I guess between you and I
oh yeah love you both love your podcast
thank you love Fisher
well it's not that I envied necessarily
but
working with Ian McKellen which we did
in the group and did every so often was
always fantastic and I remember when you
were off
kind of much more third movie with Ian
doing those scenes that were
specifically just you and E and I
remember thinking man that must be a
good day at work Billy's just hanging
out with
one of the tricks you know one of the
reasons one of the great great actors I
wonder if you thought that about you you
know I don't think you did because I
could tell by the way that he acted with
me that he didn't think yeah he just
kind of dismissed you out of hand but
that's beautiful for the whole you know
that whole scene of you saying right
well I guess we're gonna die now I
didn't think life was going to go that
way and Gandalf says oh no no it's not
over yet that's a that's a beautiful
scene in the film and must have been
great as an actor to think wow these
lines this actor and Dom's not around to
[ __ ] distract me for a change it's
quite nice no it was uh you're right Dom
uh those those moments with the you know
I'll always treasure yeah because uh as
you see he's one of the greats you know
and and I remember we had always
approached those scenes kind of like
theater you know we'd have little
rehearsals ourselves and it was really
lovely yeah I feel talking about that I
felt the same way about Miranda oh yeah
because I thought when Miranda arrived
in New Zealand I was beguiled is that
what yeah I think you can be beguiled
with someone yeah
wonderful she was beguiling she was she
was lovely incredibly talented and
lovely and and I thought oh don't get to
go with like the best person who's just
arrived yeah and uh I still feel about
that about Miranda when I watch her now
I think she's incredible actress did you
see the uh
the one uh was it Will Ferrell who was
in it about the the family in the snow
yeah it is no it's a comedy oh like the
force major thing yes it was released on
the French yeah yeah with Julia Louis
Dreyfus who's also incredible bro he's
Miranda in that mirando Not only was in
it but totally stole it she was
fantastic in it wow hilarious because
the original one the Force Major is just
the Masterpiece
um yeah and what I really like about
that relationship between Mary and eowin
is obviously with with Pippin and
Gandalf they've spent a significant
amount of time with each other and that
that relationship is has grown over time
but with Mary and eowin they have to
become very
quick friends that trust each other you
know like within a few scenes and to
earn that is kind of difficult and it's
sweet that they're kind of mirroring the
same story she's basically being
kind of sidelined by people yeah saying
you you know you're a woman you can't
fight you're supposed to be hanging out
inside and taking care of the the other
kids and women and stuff and she says no
no I I want to fight I'm someone that
that is capable and she sees that in
Mary which is why she's like look if I'm
coming if you've allowed me to come then
of course he should come to and that's a
beautiful thing yeah it's lovely she
stands up for you because she sees that
sort of minority yeah I love it yeah now
there you go lovely good question Tom
yeah
because this is from Michigan in the
United States of America it's from Drew
now Drew says hey hello Billy and Tom my
name's Drew from Michigan as we've
already said just want to say I'm a huge
fan no my question for you is going to
bring back some memories of the good old
PlayStation 2. growing up in my younger
years there was a game I'm sure you're
familiar with called loderings The
Return of the King in which there were
bonus clips and scenes about all the
hobbits talking about how good Elijah
was at gaming and all the typical banter
between you guys so my question for you
is one
do you remember this game and two what
is your favorite video game of all time
and why keep up the good work and my
best regards to you both
Video Game Stop I do remember that game
and I do remember back back at that
point Elijah was definitely
um much more of a accomplished gamer
than we were he was playing all the time
he would play on set he would play back
in La when I came to LA with Elijah we
did the whole you know Chinese man's
theater and Disneyland and stuff but in
the evening he was playing Silent Hill
Silent Hell of all things like a horror
game he loves horror doesn't it I just I
was watching it and I would say to
Elijah well I can't watch that like
turning around a corner and there's like
a dead thing coming at him not fun for
me but Elijah loved it so back then I
would argue that he was easily the best
gamer
and we would play like the streets thing
NBA Street yeah that was brilliant
wasn't it but then we improved quite
quickly and I don't think Elijah plays
as much now he's got a young family I
don't think he's had the opportunity to
play and you and I are almost
professional at League of Legends aren't
we and we did go to the league we went
to the finals the world says they call
it I hope to go Nick well next year I
think it'll be somewhere in Southeast
Asia that would be incredible I think I
know where it is but I don't know if
it's been announced so I'm not going to
say let's not say it but somewhere in
Southeast Asia yeah but wasn't that
great hey Don brilliant and I don't
think we're that far away from being
professional no it's just a little click
just a little bit we just need to tidy
up our backswing as it went like they
say in uh spine and sat there's just
that tiny little difference between
genius and stupid and I think we're on
the stupid just just a little click in
the movie Geniuses you know so I would
say my favorite video game of all time
is League of Legends really yeah that's
that's cemented now is it yeah I mean
because game times as I was growing up
that I really loved Defender
Space Invaders you know all those games
are really loved but I don't think
there's any game I've stuck as long as
League of Legends and I would I would
say you're the most improved player well
thank you is that not the award they
give to the one who doesn't get any
other Awards sometimes they give that to
someone who's just crap and they want to
give him an award but uh I think you've
gone from not only most improved to
you know playing I'm a Dinger a level
that no one else has ever played in the
history of hamadinger I think you could
be raped on good for you League of
Legends is definitely up there for me ah
is it my favorite game
it has so many enjoyable aspects to it
when you know when it's cracking off
when you're on a team with all our mates
and we're winning brilliant it is rough
to play two or three games in a row and
just get absolutely slaughtered right
it's it's kind of brutal yeah as but and
and what I would like to be
and I hope this happens sometime
I'd like to play a game where I'm not
the worst in the team and after you've
done that already I don't know if I have
really I'm I'm always the worst or
between the bottom two you know some
there has to be someone else who's
carrying it yeah but I think
statistically we talked about this the
other day I die more than you because
I'm always like getting into the fight
so a lot of times we'll end the game and
I'll see what did you get and you said I
got a B minus and I'll say I got a C
plus or a d so I think there's there's
been times where I've definitely you
know done worse than you it'll happen
yeah I can't wait just a little just a
just a little slower on the learning
ladder
that's all it's all right can you get
there so yeah a lot of times I think
probably my favorite game because it
isn't quite as brutal when you lose it
it's probably still Skyrim and the new
Skyrim they've been threatening to come
out for a long time and when that comes
out
I'll be very excited and that's just a
one player is it that's a single player
game you can play different versions of
it online that is like multiplayer but a
single player game I think I've told you
there's there's times when I've been
playing Skyrim where I thought I wonder
what the top of that mountain looks like
and I'll climb to the top of that
mountain and if you let go of your
controller for like a minute or so it'll
do a massive 360 kind of thing and the
view from the top of the mountain is so
beautiful that I'll just think I'm not
going to play the game for a little bit
I'm just going to watch that view for
five minutes amazing bunch of games yeah
well I've started doing that with the
Elder Scrolls and I'm enjoying it you
know but I want a horse yeah it takes a
while to get a horse doesn't you have to
go to a stable but you need the money to
buy it I don't think you have the money
to buy yeah do you Can you steal a horse
try it
I know it's morally wrong is still a
horse I wonder if you can have you ever
um shoot a horse
yeah I told a donkey to [ __ ] off once
hey hey hey uh Eddie have we got some
voicemails should we do this we haven't
done voicemails for a bit let's do
voicemails oh and there's this from all
over the world
here we go you ready yeah I'm ready
and I wanted to know what your favorite
type of ice cream is bye P.S I love your
show and I'm seven
I definitely sweet good nice to hear
from you
I picked my son up from school yesterday
he's no longer seven he was at one point
he's 16 now and I picked him up from
school and he went I could go ice cream
so that was his first thought did you
say to him do you have cash oh you got
any money go get a job yeah I gotcha
because uh ice cream I think is quite
important Daphne didn't tell us her
favorite ice cream flavor I'm gonna
guess vanilla Daphne right what's yours
you have to pick one
well it's difficult because it depends
where I'm going
you got the ice cream shop I don't know
but which one ah okay well what how many
have you got in your local area that you
mess about with three is it Jenny's one
of them no I'm a fan of her Journeys
never been to Jenny's shame on you but
if I had to do if I walked into a store
and I don't know the ice cream store
what flavor am I gonna get it's between
two of them pistachio it's between three
dogs
vanilla vanilla pistachio
mint chocolate chip oh no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
yes there should not be mint and
chocolate chip not together not for me
no I don't even like chocolate I kind of
like I mentioned that but the two of
them together no no no no no no okay
it's yours then am I picking three God I
just won all right you could never pick
one no way I know if I gave you a
hundred thousand dollars to do one just
know you couldn't do I can't I'm gonna
pick three I've got some controversial
ones here lemon no I'm a fan of the
lemonade
um a kind of
salted caramel
with maybe a crunchy biscuity type
caramely thing in there salted caramel
to do that at uh Jenny's ice cream and
then my final one again slightly
controversial yogurt
yogurt flavor yogurt flavored ice cream
that's weird yeah I like it's big in
Germany that's like two that's like
because yoga I don't really think of as
a flavor oh it's a flavor yeah I've bent
your brain though you have because
that's that's weird I think it
traditionally is probably more of a
vanillary type yogurt but it's good and
it's good with the lemon because you get
sharp lemon chilled out yogurt do you
make some I have them in a cone with you
know the tournament together lovely do
you have a corner do you have a bowl I
just can't I don't understand people
have a ball because you're like why
would you get a bowl you can eat the
bowl if you get a cornet
I get you but do you get a corner or a
bowl I get a coin good yeah konia normal
Corner a sugar waffle no no sugar waffle
for me it's too sugary as it is sugar
waffle for me I already feel guilty
homemade oh your wife no I understood
Daphne thanks for your question we
didn't find out what your particular
yeah favorite send us another message
Daphne tell us what your flavor is yeah
dearest Dom and Billy I love the show
your podcast is such a rare and
uplifting Gem and I'm so grateful that
you shared with the world
my name is Richard and I'm tuning in
from a small town called South
darindelcalia Sweden
I would like you to list your personal
favorite use of a swear word in any of
the Lord of the Rings films one for each
of the three following categories one
funny absurd silly two dark adding
insult to injury three use of a swear
word where it feels almost warranted to
do so
so that's funny Dark warranted I thought
that could be really funny so uh thank
you again God bless you and bye bye
thanks so much thank you from Sweden
from Sweden taxi
um
okay so
warranted I've always said that I like
the thing where Gandalf just Whispers
under his breath
I like that I think that's warranted you
know because they're always getting on
these tits you know I'll get I'll do um
dark
warranty damn dude I've done warranted
oh are we just doing one each we'll do
one each and do one each then
they're full of attack dark dumb
and you shall have a queen it's quite
scary that one oh that was yeah that was
quite dark and then let me think hold on
and dark dark
right we'll just do one for that okay
and then what's the other one uh funny
funny
I I've always liked Sam at the end of
the film well I'm coming back it's a
good one what about you with the
fireworks get the big one oh yeah again
the big one's good
Gimli in uh the passive kazadoo
quite dark as well yeah it's not that
one there we go I think we've covered it
yeah we covered it out cover that well
done well done
and Billy okay
such a rare and uplifting yeah to listen
to him complimenters again that was
awful
hi Billy and Dom my name is Dakota and
I'm from Rhode Island so I loved your
Billy and Dom eat the world bit with
coffee milk
I first saw Lord of the Rings in
theaters when I was four years old and
my mom said that people were giving her
a double take when the lights turned on
because she had a small child with her
my question for you both is what is the
funniest moment that you can remember on
the set of Lord of the Rings or are
there any funny or standout interactions
that you've had with fans over the years
anyways I love your podcast and you guys
always make my day thanks
thanks Dakota lovely stuff this wasn't
necessarily funny but I found it really
adorable and I think it's worth saying
when we were recently in San Francisco
last weekend for the League of Legends
Final as I was leaving
I met you downstairs just to give you a
hug and say hello and you headed to
breakfast and as I said bye to you a
lady walked in step with me as I was
heading to the reception area to pick up
my Uber to go to the airport and she
just whispered in my ear are you one of
our adorable Hobbits oh and I went oh I
think I am one of your adorable Hobbits
and she went great and then just walked
up it was such a nice sweet gender it's
a nice yes lovely sat so not funny but
see when I left you and I went to
um breakfast it was an awful breakfast
ah why warm was that it cooled down a
can of cold eggs and you know old bacon
and toast and just nothing really
mushrooms nothing like that and you know
yogurt and a thing that you could just
buy for like a perfect you know and and
it was a boofie and it was 50 dollars
did you pay for it I had to look at you
well is it not included in the room I'd
already sat down and he said it's a
buffet I went okay 50 bucks you're gonna
have to fill your boots for 50 bucks
that's what I was thinking I was like I
can't eat enough toast no you can't
fifty dollars I mean that is a lot
that's a lot for lunch I said I said is
that for one you say that is for one
year did you have yourself five or six
cups of coffee I bet the coffee was
awful what a week no just like uh old
come on guys we won't mention the hotel
but come on because the hotel was
actually lovely but you can't save that
as a as a breakfast and the day before
you and I walked out and we had a
fantastic breakfast at
Honeys Honeys Creperie remember lovely
and I've been before
Not only was it tasty and cheaper than
fifty dollars but during our breakfast I
found a hidden pair of boxer shorts in
the back of my knee do you remember that
so he daddy reached into his pants I
thought what's he going to pull out here
and he pulled out a pair of box of
shorts oh my God I was sitting in like
yeah I was in hysterics that was fun but
wait have we answered the question only
I bet what's the funniest thing I
haven't done do you know that day that I
thought was hilarious done and I've said
this before
when we're sitting on that little boat
and Legolas tells us about limber spirit
that was funny when it's hard to keep a
straight face could not keep a strip
it's basically after Orlando says I
don't know how to deliver this line
because it feels like I'm doing an
advert like I'm doing an ad for when by
spread after that and knowing that you
were sitting right next to me I couldn't
look at you yeah I think Pete had put as
as close to each other as we could be
for this funny kind of community moment
and we both had to play it quite deadpan
didn't we how many of you had how many
did you four and we could I could I'm
not Mary's not impressed by that at all
he's actually disappointed in Pippin and
you're kind of like what you're gonna do
yeah we were laughing a lot weren't we
that was just what look I could I had to
look at Orlando I couldn't look at you
that day was hilarious I loved that
there you go there's you there's your
answer I love that being on the edge of
like really out laughing yeah the
giggles they've been able to hold that
in and off so you can still do the scene
but you can feel it in your stomach I'm
just like oh this is yeah you can feel
the energy and every so often because
Pete's got an adorable laugh you'll hear
Pete just behind the back of the
camera's going
I love it right thanks to God anymore
should we do one more
Lisa
at your service so I know it's been 20
years since you played a lot of the
Rings are there any personality traits
from Mary and Pippin that you still hold
on to to this day if there are please
please tell us
love you guys bye thanks Lisa and
Oliveira from location unknown they
sound like Mary and Pepin right there
you had to do something up to lots of
trouble
um I don't know I mean I think Mary and
Pippin certainly in the Shire before
stuff gets serious and crazy I would
imagine that they are quite friendly
approachable Carefree Hobbits I think
you and I have elements to our
personality when we're out and about
where
we're cool with people coming over and
saying hello and we keep it pretty
mellow right yeah I think I think
there's a we've whether we've taken that
from Marion Pepin or it's already there
but I suppose we met playing Mary and
Pippin so that has definitely influenced
Who We Are
as a couple
we love our food as well Billy and I
will eat food from all over the world I
saw him at the weekend we had like a
little bit of a Thai feast
we like to celebrate those moments don't
we you know I mean we don't take that
lightly the food shows up lots of wine
enjoying ourselves that's what I like
that's that's a very Hobbit element is
if they've got the meal in front of them
their friends are around they're safe
they're gonna have a great night and I
think there's there's things about that
that we also subscribe to yeah I suppose
we're a little more adventurous I think
Mary and Pepin would have been happy
just to stay in the shower if they could
yeah they'd be quite big potatoes in the
show yeah yeah but uh yeah there's
definitely some of us there thank you
very much for that thanks Lisa and
Oliveira I think we are we going should
we do one more Eddie it seems like we've
got one more we got one more if you guys
want to do it
hi Billy and Dom my name is Rob I'm from
Canada I'm homesick right now and
catching up on some of the podcasts and
I had a question I'm a huge Lord of the
Rings fan and you can't find ethelas
plant anywhere so what is your go-to
home remedy for the common cold
thanks
good
what is your remedy
for the common cone
I suppose a lot of people get the cold
in Canada a lot of people get the cold
in Scotland or not tis the season it's
it's we're moving into cold season now
as it's getting colder what do you do if
you get cold what what is your do the
same thing that I did when I got covered
now I don't know if this necessarily uh
shortened my covid but it did help me
sleep a little better because it kind of
seemed to open up my sinuses big bottle
of water lovely either apple cider
vinegar or lemon you can choose either
one
a bit of cayenne pepper in there
maybe some ginger powder if you get it
okay Shake It Up try and drink that as
much as possible I mean obviously
staying hydrated is huge and it's
horrible when you're feeling sick and
you know a mum is a nurse and my mum
obviously always says make sure you're
hydrated and it's the last thing you
want to do is wake up and drink water
but I do think that helps sleep yeah
that's about it I keep it simple sleep
stay hydrated
be nice to yourself be gentle I do
actually do that Scottish thing of a hot
toddy oh
which uh you do in Scotland you'd even
give a version of this to kids and
everything right so explain a hot toddy
some people might not know it Whiskey
hot water
spoonful of honey
just set that before you go to bed
nothing else that's all you need little
anyone pillow oh well you wouldn't put a
cinnamon stick in there but no
absolutely absolutely not dumb I think
so this is the variations is there a
little squeezed lemon in a hot toddy
sometimes real I think what you're
finding there is your anglophing uh-huh
what you just get is the it's basically
the whiskey oh that's the whiskey
because that'll kill everything yeah
it will kill you given another thing
yeah but uh a little hot toddy I think
just before you go to sleep that's
lovely yeah Honey's good for your throat
they say for a sore throat none of this
stuff that you get from shops the two
best things for a sore throat honey yep
Magic from the bees
pineapple juice
Magic from the pineapple yeah coach's
throat lovely there's something in a
pineapple
there's a few things in the pineapple
isn't it yeah but something that's
really good for your academics oh
bromelain bromale anti-inflammatory have
you seen it looks like a a cheat to me
those people who are able to
kind of solve the problem of the
pineapple skin like they'll be like this
is how I take it yeah and they kind of
turn upside down and punch it and then
and then the pineapple skin just falls
off it comes out in blocks yeah you're
like come on wait a minute have you
prepared it and now you're showing us
you know prepared that I've never heard
prepare said in that way and it makes
more sense yeah well it's isolate the
word pre have you done something before
and then the paired it um
that was a good question it was a
fantastic question there from Rob sorry
that you're feeling homesick Rob and uh
may be getting a cold oh don't say that
right I'm all right now hey Billy what
should we eat the world
billion Dom eat the world William what
is it you and I are big fans of uh food
we're big fans of food from around the
world we're a big fan of spice oh I love
space and this was sent to us by Kai
Sadler in Denair California he said hey
Billy Don my name's Kai 27 years old I
live in Denair California it is a small
town in the heart of farming country
located in North Central California as a
native California born and raised in the
agriculturally diverse area I would like
to share with you one of our most
commonly grown Commodities almonds or as
some people say almonds what would you
say almonds I'd say almonds oh well
there you go did you know that the state
of California produces 80 of the world's
almonds and 100 of the United States
commercial Supply wow Blue Diamond
Growers has a wide selection of flavored
almonds and I've chosen for you my my
true oh for you to try my personal
favorite which is wasabi and soy sauce
do we have that one Eddie are you
bringing it in I'm a fan of Wasabi
inside here it comes from one foodie to
a pair of others I'm confident that you
will both enjoy their bold tantalizing
taste I hope you're inspired to try the
other flavor varieties as well in the
future thanks Eddie I thoroughly enjoy
listening to your podcast and appreciate
the positive masculinity that you both
put out into the universe oh I didn't
realize that we were bringing a positive
masculine I think we are actually done
well I've had these before I've had
really yeah on planes
what was Serbian soy yeah Wasabi inside
here well I'm not 100 positive but I
think so normally you just heat up your
nuts on a plane yeah how do you um
where do you stand on the whole uh no
preferences are you are you a fan of the
other nut I love nuts I absolutely love
nuts give us your top three nuts
Chestnut
because you're not
being Pistachio Pistachio well done
yeah because you love pistachios you eat
a lot oh that's fun but Chestnut that's
kind of out of the box you're only
having it kind of around Christmas time
right I'll round about now don't there's
nothing I would like more grilled little
salt then walk around
a cool Street mahuda
I've got I've got you in my hands you're
holding my handy yeah I'm trying to keep
you warm you're lovely she asked Notch
and we get to a city Square
just as the clocks
ringing nine oh it's dark out can I be
your little kid Oh Daddy Oh no you're
stole you oh I wanted to be your little
kid no oh I died look at that it's still
you okay and we've got a walk to the
hotel right it's 30 minutes oh God and
you're like that I'm freezing say that
I'm really I'm freezing don't worry it's
all not only that I'm a bit peckish well
the very thing here look over there well
oh a lady uh with a dog and a dog's
having a [ __ ] just to the rate of that
yeah you see who that is is that Steve
Jobs no that's a man
he looks like that guy it does look like
Steve Jobs but his absolute is a German
it's a German gentleman
and he's Russian chestnuts he's roasting
chestnuts you say right and what how
what we're gonna do we're going to just
come on the walk home well I'm gonna
walk home we'll get a baggage oh cause
you want you warm your hands up with him
you warm your hands up and watch he's
broken his shells so you can get them
out perfectly my only critique of that
would be how do you access the salt
because I like to dip them in a little
bit of salt
oh there's no salt it's just a chestnut
just as it comes right I like the
chestnut that is my favorite nut and the
fit my favorite we eat that nut well
I'll tell you what if you and I are ever
in a situation where we're walking
through a cold area and I see a chestnut
seller it's on me every single time I
will take it every day I've came out of
restaurants full as a woke as they would
say it was a Bandit's rifle and I I will
buy myself a chestnuts well just for the
flavor see the flavor of these nuts I
think we've been offered here by Kai
absolutely delicious these are lovely
these are blue diamond Wasabi and soy
sauce nuts and can I say I think a
lovely way to uh Chase these would be
with a lovely cold lager I love what you
know what I mean yeah maybe on a plane
lovely little glass of Stella Artois
something like that dumb my three
favorite nuts you were just about to ask
pistachios number one oh no no
stuff no specific okay I think I just
have to give him a top three because but
no specific God I can't like carry on
pistachios
it's hard to mess with the cashew
and then my last one man this is tough
because I've not met a knot that I don't
like a walnut lava will not come in the
house right now I like a pecan
like a royal I'll say almonds because I
eat almonds probably more than any other
nut and they're quite a healthy maybe
not like this but a raw almond really
quite healthy Dom protein does your wife
like nuts no not not the way
she likes a chocolate with a hazelnut
um well the only hazelnut Hazelnut and
chocolate is an incredible taste profile
together she there's a chocolate bar
that she likes
excuse me
and they do it in peanut caramel fruit
and nut hazelnut
she won't take it anyway except are you
talking about just the the whole not
bars that what you mean yeah what do you
mean well that I think it's called a
whole nut when it comes as just a milk
chocolate with hazelnuts no it's not a
Cadbury one A different one it's a
little block okay I don't know who makes
that
um now what about your dog if you
approached your dog with a knot would
you reject it I don't know if you can
give dogs nuts I thought that was
chocolate or onions onions or grapes
didn't know that about what so what
happens with an onion or a grape in a
dog's body toxic wow
nothing can maybe assuming nuts I'm not
sure
don't do that then I'll check that for
you though yeah I remember we were
hanging out in the garden one time
eating fruit and I was chatting with
your dog and I went down to give him a
grape and you went do not
poison my dog I didn't even know yeah
the things you have to learn there yeah
I've never had a dog one day
that maybe
my favorite ever almond
it's great and and the flavor is quite
intense for the first second or so and
then it eases off but
and then it makes you grab another one
because you want that intensity again I
like foods that make you salivate
I think this is
got any facts on it I'll give you a
little fact here the Blue Diamond
Growers is an agricultural cooperative
and marketing organization that
specializes in California almonds
founded in 1910 as the California
almonds Growers exchange this
organization claimed to be the world's
largest tree nut processing and
marketing company it serves three and a
half thousand almond Growers and helps
make the Almond crop valued at over a
million oh California's largest food
export
Eddie could you bring me some water
before I die
willing could you speak because I don't
think I'm close to death you probably
have you probably have to watch how many
if you're watching your calories oh talk
us through the calories we hear this
um oh no
just the whole pot Eddie thank you so
much
thank you very much
um I thought as I said there for
servings
and I won't tell you how many calories
because I'll let you uh guess
but I thought it said six nuts and then
it was as many calories but it's not
it's 28 knots how many calories in 28
knots just to clarify 28 knots is seen
as one serving yes
I would say how many we're close to that
aren't we for what we got I would say we
had more like 40 nuts really
right how many calories in 28 knots I'm
going to say
300 too much
I've said too much yeah
150 too low 200 too much
175 too much
160. too little 165 until
163 too little
164 too low what it's 165 was too little
167 too well 169 too little
170 yeah I said
107.75 we'll play it back and I'll show
you oh you might be right that's quite a
lot is that quite a lot I don't know no
we're not when it was six nuts I thought
it was a lot about 28 and that's a
couple hundred not bad not all right a
little bit of fat in there a little bit
of protein yeah good protein let me see
if I can guess the gram does it tell you
the grams of protein in the serving yep
two and a half grams of protein
pair seven
six grams oh it's quite a lot it's good
after the gym it's quite good doesn't it
how much fat saturated not tall tall fat
three grams
20. oh wow oh wait a minute hang on
William 15. still quite a lot isn't it
that's a lot of fat but it's good fat
isn't it well that's what people would
say it's good fats good fat babies
because it was good fat for you but we
unsaturated mono monosaturated yeah good
fats is the fats that occur in foods
like the fat and salmon maybe the fat in
chicken the fat the fat avocado avocado
grape fat but the the man-made fats are
the ones that you want to try and avoid
right yeah trans fats trans fats do you
know how much trans fat no none oh good
well look I'm not sure if we can find
anything else you want some more facts
you won't be giving facts the company
produces almonds in various forms
included roasted almonds Under the Blue
Diamond Brand and almond milk under the
Almond Breeze blend oh yeah yeah the
Cooperative is privately held and does
not disclose sales figures however
although the Sacramento Bay estimated to
have annual sales of over 709 million in
2009 that's the last Almost a billion a
year now I bet well that's good it's a
thing as a Cooperative the way well now
explain to me about cooperatives that
mean that the people who work there also
own some of the profits yeah actually I
would I would um I think it would be
lovely so it serves three three and a
half thousand almond Growers cool
that's good and all of those almond
Growers get to share in the profits of
the company yeah that's uh is that is
that socialism all right yeah
organization is headquartered in
Sacramento
um
oh yeah man oh hang on it resisted
attempts by the international Longshore
and Warehouse Union to organize workers
that's not good is it so you weren't
allowing um unions
um
oh no
you can't read it yeah it looks like you
didn't get the unions working for them
but um oh I'm gonna look into that more
but I think if it is a co-op and the
actual guys
who are growing the almonds is um
yeah are sharing in the profits that's
fantastic isn't it yeah it is it's
fantastic I'd like to uh go they're only
in Sacramento we could go visit these
guys yeah we'll eat some nuts why do
they why do you think
nuts are commonly served on planes
what's that about
do you think it's a it's an easy
it's an easy snack it's a natural snack
and it maybe gets you ready for your
aperitif
as you say it puts you in the mid for a
beer or something oh it does yeah
because there's salt is it
salt yeah it might be a bit thirsty
that's a good point actually maybe they
try to give you something too quit wet
your appetite get you ready as it were
what's your talk to me I mean I've been
on many planes with you but you like to
be left alone on a plane I've noticed
yeah I don't I don't want it don't let
me bother you don't want to chat you
don't want to watch a movie together
none of that stuff none of that um it's
my own experience a point I understand
but talks me through that when you get
on do you do you have a magazine are you
listening to a podcast when you get on
how do you settle in I'll normally I
always have a book
because I find I will watch a movie Once
the movie Once the plane's up and going
usually
no I'm usually Interstellar but um when
it you know you've got your kind of
watch what's going on and listen to the
safety thing and all that and they ask
you to turn your phone off I'm like what
is it I mean there's a lot going on I'll
just rather sit with my book
so I'm reading to take off then normally
the book goes away and then I'm on the
screen Interstellar and Interstellar or
maybe some music and then I like to have
a nap on a point I know for lunch before
dinner you like to have a quick kind of
45 minute hour long thing no after after
sailing with a film if it's a long
flight and then hopefully doze off
whilst watching a film maybe can't do
that oh you go watch it till the end I
just can't I my brain is too engaged in
a film to switch off it has to watch it
I can take the headphones off put an eye
mask on fall asleep but listening to a
film you know I find it too well I think
in general you're more awake than you
are asleep and I think I'm more asleep
than I'm awake
yeah it might be true might be true I
like we've been flying around with um
Elijah Wood and uh Sean Aston quite a
lot easily and Elijah and I like to sit
together because we like to be quite
interactive on playing together a large
knives you guys chatting on we're
chatting we're talking about you know
showing each other magazine of course
maybe we're sharing games we might watch
the uh occasional film and Elijah enjoys
uh gin and tonic on a plane well there's
nothing wrong with that film he said to
us one of the funniest things he said to
us is um there is no time in the sky
um so regardless of what time we're
flying uh Tradition now Elijah and I is
to have one or maybe seven gin and
tonics lovely stuff it could be nicer
one of the recent uh live podcasts that
we did I showed up a little a little
tipsy from my flight yeah everyone can
go back and watch friendship onions and
tell us which one it was that almost
slightly Tipsy yes yes
um well should we give it some scores oh
yeah I forgot about that we've got to
score it bills taste well the taste is
Top Notch this particular almond not all
almonds we're talking about the soy and
wasabi almond here from um Blue Diamond
you're a fan of Wasabi I've had a lot of
sushi dinners with you and you're a fan
of Wasabi it's a horseradish Wasabi I
love wasab and I love it on peas you
know when you get the peas love it and
it goes right up the back of your nose
like English mustard oh it's a love-hate
thing and you can have the Wasabi paste
which is fine but if you had the actual
oh Wasabi that stuff is
all right
um
the taste of this particular Blue
Diamond Omen the soy Wasabi it's
fantastic
William
oh I tend to him I've got to give this
a 9.5 you're loving it that's one of my
highest scores
I'll give it an 8.9 still good oh it's
fantastic I loved it aesthetic the nuts
well it's an almond and the Box
it's an almond I appreciate
the lovely guy please like a mirac Le I
appreciate the warning it's giving you
when you're looking at it because it's
saying to you hey we're covered in a
dust a hot dust
you know I'd like you wouldn't like it
well I'd like the dust at the bottom of
that tin
no I'd like to dip my wet finger into
the bottom and eat the Dust
you push your fingers past my nuts just
to get to the dust oh yeah well
um I mean it's
those it's an almond doesn't it I mean
can you dress it up any more than that
it's a good looking nut though ain't
that yeah like I don't I don't
aesthetically I don't like the look of a
walnut
looks like a brain yeah that's
interesting because it's good for your
brain of Walnut yeah it's like a walnut
whip no not really I don't like
chocolate we've already got into this
well how would you describe the shape of
an almond because that must have a name
that shape it doesn't you know what this
ship is well almond ship no I swear it's
got to have a nut really
since you met somebody who looked like
that you'd say
he had a sort of almond-shaped face an
almond-shaped face yeah wow um
well I'll be kind
I'll give it a six for the Aesthetics
it's nice but it's not gonna I'm waiting
you wouldn't write home about it
if it really is a co-op
no you can't talk about that that's not
about the look of it the Aesthetics of
the thing
Aesthetics of the Box we talk about the
Box what does the Box have to do with
the co-op well aesthetically
it looks like a corporation
and if it is a co-op I wouldn't want to
look like this all right
so I think if it is a co-op
aesthetically the box is wrong why what
would you change about the box would you
have everyone's face on it that's
involved with the co-op some people
maybe not all three and a half thousand
but I would have like blue diamond Co-op
and we support the farmer or something
you know what I mean
the actual almond I do like the look of
it and I like the dust well it's almond
shape yeah I would say I'm gonna give it
an eight
how useful is an almond and more of the
point how useful is an almond with the
flavor of soy and wasabi
I have a a little
box in my kitchen full of raw almonds
raw pecans and raw walnuts and it is my
post gym snack if I'm not able to like
eat anything really quickly I'll eat a
couple of handfuls of that because it's
some nice fats and nice proteins so
that's post gym it's a very useful snack
isn't it and you it's so easy to have
there keep them in your car in a little
Ziploc bag
so that's useful how long do nuts last
I mean I think they do have a shelf life
but it must be quite long because
um
they don't tend to degrade that much do
they yeah but like once it's open I mean
I don't know I don't I don't know you
know I couldn't even begin to guess do
you have a of all things
personal and mortar I do have a pestle
and mortar yeah now do you not feel if
you had uh 10 of these
and wasabi and soy sauce uh Blue Diamond
almonds
and you pestle and mortar them yeah so
much you could do
oh yeah
sprinkle that in an ice cream that'd be
nice maybe a vanilla ice cream with a
little thing on like that on top if you
were making a bread put it into the
bread I like that so even if all you had
was flour milk
eggs
a self-raising yeast you could make a
snack make a bread with that yeah you
could put it on a pie
put on a pie a little little spicy kick
obviously Wasabi is greatly used in
Sushi yeah whether it's a fine powder
could you sprinkle it on top of a soup
like a like a rainbow roll or something
pretty good couldn't you if you're
making a stir fry throw some of them in
at the end along with their onions just
out of the microwave yeah Dom that's
high scores for me I think it's going to
be up there for me
I'm going to say a 9.8 I'm going to see
a 9.9 this is very high scores for you
this is one you can tell that how many I
think it will I think if you don't mind
no please
well Eddie I have to say that was a
fantastic billion to all meet the world
yes and that was brought to us by the
illustrious and wonderful cat hi Sadler
thank you Kai from California who not
only recommended something that they
like but something associated with their
local area and yeah right in the heart
of the farming country in North Central
California I'm sure that's beautiful up
there I must be we should go up there
and
really get a handful of nuts yeah I'd
love that well we've got one last
potential thing to do here which is and
we've not done it for a while should we
listen to it should we do just to finish
this one off because it's been a lovely
episode if you don't mind me saying dumb
I don't mind at all I've loved it I'm
still nibbling on my nuts over here
because I was slightly stressed when I
got here there's a lot going on
and I've enjoyed their little lower
together done I've enjoyed it too I saw
that when when I showed up I thought oh
what's on Billy's mind there was a lot
in my mind you know
I've checked it twice I like to make a
list when I've when I've got stuff going
on in my mind because we had Rob Cody on
the show and he said
there's something that you think of try
and get it down either in your phone or
on your list because then it's not
floating around your brain in a
distracted way and then you can you can
put a line through it once you strike it
off I think was the phrase very good
very good all right so let's do a little
funky For You music Dom if music be the
food of love let's eat it exactly
[Music]
you you introduced this song Billy
ladies and gentlemen red bone their name
and Nod to their Heritage was a Native
American band from kulinga California
led by the brothers Pat and candido or
Lolly Vasquez
they were managed by bumps Blackwell who
gated Little Richard and Sam Cooke to
success wow to avert discrimination he
convinced the brothers to use a
different last name so they became known
as Pat and Lawley Vegas that was good no
Redbone and an audience playing clubs on
the Sunset Strip in Los Angeles at the
same time the doors were on that scene
and they have a song here now Dom and I
think you'll enjoy this it's called come
and get your love yes and it was uh sent
To Us by Kayla in California let's make
California sure this is yeah can we Cali
[Music]
hey okay
[Music]
nothing but matter with you
I don't know what's a matter of
Tom lovely lovely stuff there from
Redbone
would you hang it up I've heard that
song before I haven't all I think that's
featured in
um maybe some films about Vietnam
something like that would it would it be
fair yeah you know the the American
troops over in Vietnam listening to it
like a hamburger Hill type thing or a
girl
[Music]
Maybe
that could be
isn't it yeah ish 1970 yeah so yeah
you're not likely to forget oh
you're not likely to forget the title of
the song the chorus is comprised with
the same line come and get your love
repeated four times the verses are very
compact so after two minutes you've
already heard the first two verses and
the two chorus repetitions the song then
goes into a bridge which repeats
variations on the chorus
there are some musical elements in the
song that make it very hard to get out
of your head once it's buried in a big
part of that is the extended hail
shouted back SEC uh several times in the
song Oh included in the beginning
[Applause]
yeah it's a great song
Girls Just Wanna Have Fun now
um
as a follow-up single Redbone wanted to
release a song called we were all
wounded at Wounded Knee song about the
1890 massacre in South Dakota
um but their label Epic Records knew
that this would be a career killer and
refuse although they did press copies
that were distributed in Europe instead
they release vote
was released as their next single that
song is about there
pouty leader who introduced The Ghost
Dance into the culture as a way of
connecting souls and preserving their
heritage
after the Wounded Knee Massacre a far
cry from come and get your love it made
just
101 yeah
Redbone never had a higher hit on the
channel beggar you see now that's that's
terrible in it you see that's big
commercialism saying you can't release
things about your heritage yeah don't
don't bring out a piece of art bring out
a piece of Commerce we want you to make
money not actually say something there
might be some exceptions but I'm sure
there is exceptions but
I hear what you're saying and there's
definitely a lot of you I think that's
just my brain won't go to that place
Johnny Hates Jazz no I don't think they
I don't know
but we are actually killed the cat
no but that was a great band Misfit
remember Misfit Misfit Misfit you break
down some Street no there's a gym
um and the lead singer that uh band was
called Ben hey I remember how you doing
I'm sorry I can't get through but you're
leaving me
and I'll get right back to you curiosity
killed the cat great son everybody had
it as their answer phone remember yeah
it was obnoxious and no one has uh no
one leaves messages anymore do they like
if I call someone and it goes to a voice
message I never leave a message I just
got off at that point do you just I'll
leave a message do you
check my messages anymore I'm going to
put curiosity killed the cat on mine do
it today do it hey how are you doing I'm
sorry you didn't get through
remember my one in New Zealand was
um
the start of While My Guitar Gently
reaps
and I would be on the other side of the
room on my on my answer machine and I'd
be like hi hang on I'm I'm on my way and
I get closer and close to the phone and
then as I got to the uh phone just as
well Alex uh Gently Weeps kicks in I go
leave a message
who plays the early guitar on my guitar
gentle which While My Guitar Gently lips
Eric Clapton yeah thank you the only uh
guest lead guitarist on any Beatles
song he loved Eric Clapton
brilliant guitar solo as well William I
think we've run out of time well we have
to give a marks for red bones come and
get your love ah good point
uh in a scale from Brahms Brahms friends
at his most princess and his most funky
it's funky it's funky yeah it's funky um
I'm gonna say
I'll say curiosity killed the cat funky
lovely perfect hey how are you doing I
on the other hand we'll see early Stevie
Wonder oh yeah lovely will we leave it
at that John
what was uh Stevie Wonder's initial name
for him when he came out
wasn't Stevie Wonder little Stevie
Wonder well done ten points what was the
original name of Simon and Garfunkel
when he first came out Garfunkel and
Steven now what was that again it's a
good one I'll give you a clue yeah it's
the name of an iconic animated Duo
Tom and Jerry correct answer thank you
isn't that crazy that first came out
it's Tom and Jerry what was The Beatles
first band Johnny and the moon dogs
and then The Quarrymen well done
we gotta go ladies and gentlemen the
things you've learned this week on the
Friendship onion and it was all free it
was it was free thanks for um Coming and
saying hello please subscribe rate
review if you are again touchless you
can do that all the common places you
can watch us on YouTube you can get you
can get merchandise it's fantastic at
the Friendship onionpodcast.com why not
you'll look cool Santa's a funky song
send us your ideas for foods that you
want us to eat I will see you next week
bye
[Music]
harmonize with me tighter all through
the night you're shining bright I'm your
place the baby you're my
[Music]